la segunda ley de la termodinámica una
de sus premisas es que la entropía del
universo solo aumenta y lo puse entre
signos de exclamación porque me parece
que es una afirmación muy profunda y en
muchos niveles lo es y solo para que
entremos en la misma línea de
pensamiento tengo aquí esta imagen del
cielo nocturno tomada por el telescopio
hubble y cada uno de estos puntos estos
no son estrellas
estos son galaxias esto es una galaxia
esto es otra galaxia esto es otra
galaxia y vamos a pensar en lo que esto
nos está diciendo en realidad la
entropía del universo solo aumenta a la
entropía la podemos definir como el
nivel de desorden de un sistema y
realmente estamos hablando del número de
estados que un sistema podría asumir en
este caso estamos hablando del universo
pero también podríamos decir que la
entropía de un sistema cerrado solo
aumenta
el universo es un sistema que está
totalmente contenido que no está
interactuando con su entorno porque el
universo es el sistema cerrado final no
hay nada con lo que pueda interactuar
termodinámicamente fuera de él y voy a
hacer un repaso rápido de los sistemas
abiertos y cerrados sólo para
asegurarnos de que entendemos bien este
concepto
así que si tuviera una fogata tengo aquí
algo de madera y tenemos fuego justo así
esta es nuestra fogata si solamente me
fijara en los troncos y el fuego esto va
a ser un sistema abierto porque
claramente está interactuando
termodinámicamente con su entorno está
liberando calor y está calentando las
moléculas de aire a su alrededor está
liberando luz hacia el universo podría
haber interacciones provenientes del
resto del universo hacia el sistema por
lo tanto no está aislado del resto del
universo pero un sistema cerrado es
aislado y es muy difícil crear un
sistema realmente cerrado en nuestra
vida cotidiana pero podemos tener algo
aproximado probablemente uno que ya has
visto antes es una hielera en una
hielera estamos intentando aislar
termodinámicamente el interior de la
hielera del exterior del resto del
universo y la forma en que lo hacemos es
mediante algún tipo de material aislante
tal vez con algo de poliestireno
extruido y podríamos usarla para
almacenar hielo
no es un sistema cerrado perfecto porque
eventualmente el calor del resto del
universo calentará las paredes de la
hielera y ese calor será transferido al
hielo calentando lo y derritiendo lo así
que no es un sistema cerrado perfecto
pero es una buena aproximación porque
estamos al menos intentando aislarlo
termodinámicamente del resto del
universo podríamos incluso ponerle una
tapa para demostrar que realmente
queremos aislarlo y en los laboratorios
de investigación veras cosas que son
mucho mejores aproximaciones de sistemas
cerrados pero incluso esos sistemas en
algún nivel van a interactuar con el
resto del universo este es un sistema
cerrado el único sistema cerrado real es
el universo no hay nada con lo que pueda
interactuar termodinámicamente fuera del
mismo vamos a pensar un poco acerca de
esta definición la entropía del universo
solo aumenta porque esto nos genera el
sentido de manera intuitiva
el mejor ejemplo que puedo pensar para
ello es la difusión
vamos a decir que tengo un contenedor
tengo este contenedor y lo voy a hacer
un recipiente cerrado vamos a decir que
esto es un sistema cerrado ideal teórico
ahora vamos a decir que hay gas ideal
dentro del contenedor tenemos algunas
moléculas de gas ideal justo aquí
tienen una temperatura promedio y eso
significa que cada una tiene su propia
energía cinética todos están rebotando
de maneras diferentes qué va a pasar con
el tiempo bueno con el tiempo los de
aquí de la izquierda van a rebotar en
esta pared y luego van a ir en esta
dirección
y así con el tiempo vas a tener una
situación donde el sistema se va a ver
algo así nuestro sistema se va a ver
algo así donde estas seis partículas se
van a difundir por el contenedor van a
ocupar más del espacio del contenedor
ahora bien que acaba de suceder en este
proceso bueno cuando las partículas
estaban contenidas en esta pequeña
sección del recipiente había menos
estados posibles había una entropía
menor que aquí cuando el contenedor está
lleno hay más lugares posibles y más
orientaciones posibles para las
partículas por lo tanto va a haber más
estados hay una mayor entropía mayor
entropía
y en general estos procesos donde la
entropía aumenta los llamamos procesos
irreversibles y réver
porque son irreversibles bueno hay
cierta posibilidad de que estas
moléculas se reúnan de nuevo en este
rincón del contenedor pero es una
probabilidad muy muy baja y esto es
cuando estamos lidiando con seis
moléculas pero en los sistemas reales
estaríamos hablando de mucho más que
seis moléculas vamos a estar hablando de
millones de millones de millones de
millones de moléculas cifras con entre
20 y 30 ceros de moléculas y así es muy
poco probable que todas ellas choquen de
la manera correcta para comenzar a
ocupar un volumen menor cuando en
realidad podrían llenar el recipiente es
por eso que normalmente no vemos que el
humo por ejemplo tome algún tipo de
forma de manera natural o que ocupen
menos espacio en vez de llenar su
contenedor por lo tanto esto es
irreversible ya que pasamos de un número
menor de estados posibles con un volumen
más pequeño a un mayor número de estados
posibles y el universo está haciendo
esto constantemente es por eso que la
entropía del universo solo está
incrementando hay algunos procesos en
los que se percibe que la entropía no
está aumentando mucho si tuvieras una
bola de billar por aquí la hicieras
rodar hacia otra bola de billar por aquí
y transferir el momento
otra bola nos da la impresión de que se
podría revertir es decir que la otra
bola de billar podría llegar a esta e
irse hacia atrás y a un nivel macro se
siente como si se tratara de un proceso
reversible y la gente tiende a llamar
esto o reversible y da la apariencia de
que la entropía no incrementa mucho y
solo para que quede claro cuando esta
bola está en movimiento y ésta se
encuentra estática ir a un estado en el
que ésta se mueve y ésta se encuentra
estática no parece que la entropía esté
aumentando mucho y es por eso que
tienden a llamar a esto reversible
porque se observa desde un nivel en que
las cosas podrían ir en reversa ésta
podría chocar con esta y luego ésta
podría ir hacia atrás como si pudieras
rebobinar la película pero incluso así
si lo viéramos a un nivel microscópico
verías que se está generando algo de
calor y que algunas moléculas en la
pelota están entrando en un estado
excitado ya que chocan entre sí
la fricción con el aire y ruedan por el
suelo y nunca se va a conseguir que esas
moléculas regresen al estado en que
estaban antes en realidad la entropía si
está aumentando en el sistema aun cuando
en nuestra vida diaria en termodinámica
la gente habla de procesos reversibles
son sólo aproximadamente reversibles en
los que la entropía solo ha aumentado un
poco no es que no haya aumento en la
entropía en las reacciones irreversibles
la difusión es un ejemplo muy bueno
donde es muy evidente que hay un aumento
en la entropía y se siente que existe
una probabilidad muy baja o casi nula de
que el sistema regrese a donde estaba al
inicio y no es algo que vayamos a
observar porque estamos hablando de
muchas moléculas una cifra con 20 o 30
ceros de moléculas las probabilidades de
que todas ellas se muevan de la manera
correcta son muy bajas podrías esperar
un tiempo muy largo y en realidad nunca
observar que esto suceda
espero que esto te genere sentido que el
desorden el número de estados sólo
aumenta conforme hay más y más
interacciones y mucho de eso viene del
calor todo lo que estás haciendo en este
momento cuando estoy haciendo este vídeo
mi cuerpo está generando calor ese calor
se disipa en el universo y eso solo se
suma al número de estados que el
universo puede asumir
conforme muevo mis manos y el lápiz
digital que estoy usando está causando
fricción y está liberando calor al
universo mi computadora está liberando
calor al universo mientras ves este
vídeo estás liberando calor al universo
los electrones que viajan por el cable
hacia tu computadora están liberando
calor al universo y todo eso está
aumentando el número de estados del
universo y si estás pensando a un nivel
molecular aumenta el número de estados
de todo